yeah so what what you're calling
concession there I use the term
compromise and it's like you you have
your values you know your health your
goals your dreams your everything that's
a value to you and every time you betray
that not only you are you compromising
your values but but your own sense of
self-respect and and honor
and uh just power as a as a man as a
human and um yeah and if it goes too
far what's left I mean you know it can
really it can like death really the the
death of the man that you could have
been like he's died so how does a man
come back from that in a relationship
where that's gone that far is there like
uh you know in The Matrix there's Kung
Fu training to deal with agent Smith you
know is it for for you have you have you
participated in any kind of I don't know
Workshop or training or for leadership
or conflict resolution or or
communication that's helped you to
better navigate these
conflicts yeah I mean there's any number
of angles that I've you know uh D sorry
uh Dove down these rabbit holes on as
far as you know Solutions with this
anything from psychedelics just down to
the uh basics of um frame and you know
these long-term type of relation ship um
you know
it's it's like one of these puzzles that
you throw on the table and it's got like
a thousand
pieces you can't just throw a couple
pieces together and go okay you know
it's solved like if I just Chase
Excellence not women and put a Dy
Universe I'll never have an issue again
and then that's when the uh like the
black pill crowd goes well Brad Pit
couldn't do it Johnny Depp couldn't do
it you know what makes you think that
you're going to do it now sort of thing
and they have a valid argument right but
like I said you know this is like a a
puzzle with a thousand pieces and if
you're not getting everything right it's
it's not it's not a good look and it's
not a uh favorable outcome you know for
most men um most guys don't follow the
advice that they're given they really
don't you know so I had a consult this
morning so I mean like you know to this
point of doing the work and guys fixing
their discrepancies uh a long-term
relationship and again like this is for
you this is not specifically for her or
for or for you to able to be able to
maintain the long-term relationship but
I had this consult with this guy like
three four years ago 6'3 170 pounds and
he's and he's struggling with some
issues you know with women and one of
the pieces of advice I gave him at the
time is fix your look you know you're
basically a tall skinny twig you don't
resemble the masculine virtues strength
courage Mastery honor like you don't
look like a man you know you look like a
tall skinny kind of goof goofy sort of
guy so I said to him you know get
yourself a trainer he's got lots of
money does very well in business like
he's a weapon in life but he's but he's
a skinny kind of goofy guy right and you
know when you can fix that like a six
foot3 guy that's in a masculine frame
not like a bodybuilder but somebody that
looks like what women are typically
attracted to and what is the optimal
Health angle probably about 210 215
pounds you know lean with some muscle on
and broad shoulders narrow waist he he
did nothing with the advice that I gave
him three you know three or four years
ago in that area only
but work is dressed in overalls right
and it's hard and it requires changes in
you know your schedule and your beliefs
and the way that you see and approach
the world um it's not to get women or to
keep women around this is first and
foremost you for yourself so you can
live in a strong body you should also do
it uh because it happens to attract
women though right and it happens to
keep women around when you got yourself
sorted aisle so you know to the point of
our guys doing the work are they
following the advice that's given to
them I think for the vast majority of
them the answer to that unfortunately
happens to be no
um very very few guys will do what's
required of them to be Legends in their
own world you know what I mean um it's
far easier to just sort of play the
victim mindset oh it's not Fair
society's not fair government taxes me
too much women aren't uh anything
special today you know women aren't
worth it you know why would I do all
this work you know just for a woman sort
of thing I mean at the bare minimum
making making good money you know being
being able to access resources being
able to make it rain and living in a
strong masculine body that's not for
chicks that's for you beautiful women
are probably just a byproduct of that
when you're a topshelf man so there's a
lot of like guys sort of uh resigning
themselves to the victim mindset you
know that's what the whole black pill is
is they're not really looking for
Solutions they're looking more for
sympathy you know from the world and uh
I get it you know work is tough but it
is what it is you know you want to make
something of yourself men men on the
sexual Marketplace compete and women
choose that's just the way that it is
that's the way that it's always
been I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out